c'est un scénario digne d'un film
d'espionnage quatre dirigeants d
entreprise française amesys et necsa
technologies ont été mises en examen
pour avoir fourni du matériel de
cybersurveillance à la libye et à
l'egypte pour traquer ses opposants elle
est mise en examen ont été décidées par
des juges d'instruction du pôle crimes
contre l'humanité du tribunal judiciaire
de paris
mais alors qui sont ces hommes on a
d'abord philippe vannier président de la
société amesys jusqu'en 2010 il a été
mise en examen dans le volet libyen pour
complicité d'actes de torture ensuite il
ya olivier bohbot président de
l'entreprise necsa renault rock dg de
necsa et stéphane saliès ancien
président de necsa et ex-directeur
commercial d'amesys ils ont été mis en
examen pour complicité d'actes de
torture et de disparitions forcées dans
le dossier égyptien
mais commençons par le volet libyen dans
ses mises en examen plusieurs
personnalités politiques vont être
mentionné dont mouammar kadhafi ou
encore nicolas sarkozy mais pour
comprendre il faut remonter à l'époque
de ce qu'on a appelé le printemps arabe
en 2011 des journalistes du wall street
journal et de wikileaks révèle que la
société française amesys avait équipé le
centre de surveillance d'internet de
tripoli d'un logiciel nommé i go un
système qui permet de contrôler les
échanges de messages à l'échelle du pays
il a permis entre autres de repérer des
opposants les emprisonner et les
tortures et la société française amesys
reconnaît avoir fourni au gouvernement
de kadhafi ce qu'ils appellent du
matériel danalyse dès 2007 il le
confirme
ces contrats avaient été signés dans un
contexte particulier celui du
rapprochement entre kadhafi et sarkozy
le journal mediapart avait même mis la
main sur les contrats qui lient et
l'entreprise française au gouvernement
libyen négocié par l'intermédiaire de
ziad takieddine entre 2013 et 2015 si
victimes se sont constituées parties
civiles et ont été entendus par les
juges français
elles racontent les tortures infligées
dans les prisons de kadhafi toutes ces
victimes avaient été confrontés à leurs
échanges de mails
âge pendant les interrogatoires
direction l'egypte maintenant c'est le
sujet de la deuxième instruction
judiciaire ouverte en 2017 qui vise la
vente au gouvernement d'abdel fattah
al-sisi par l'entreprise necsa
technologie d'un logiciel appelé
cérébraux utilisé pour traquer les
opposants en 2014
officieusement il aurait servi à mettre
la main sur ce qui dérange le pouvoir
égyptien
d'après télérama cette enquête a été
lancée par une plainte de la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme et
de la ligue des droits de l'homme avec
le soutien du caillou institute for
human rights et à 10 en 2010 est des
mises en examen
saluée par les deux institutions à
l'origine des plaintes
c'est une formidable avancée qui
signifie que ce que nous constatons tous
les jours sur le terrain à savoir et les
liens entre l'activité de ces
entreprises de surveillance et les
violations des droits humains peut
recevoir une qualification pénale et
donné lieu à des inculpations pour
complicité marquant ainsi un recul de
l'impunité nous espérons que cette
accélération tant attendu de la
procédure judiciaire se poursuivra et
que les autorités françaises
s'engageront résolument à prendre toutes
les mesures pour empêcher l'exportation
de technologies de surveillance à double
usage vers des pays qui viole gravement
les droits humains
cette affaire démontre que tel n'a pas
été le cas jusqu'à présent
ces organisations appellent le
gouvernement français à empêcher
l'exportation de technologies de
surveillance vers des pays qui violent
les droits humains ceci étant il faut
reconnaître que dans un monde idéal la
surveillance des citoyens tout court
quelle qu'elle soit dans des démocraties
où pas pose des problèmes d'éthique et
devrait être interdite